I want you to meet mrs. Mary Cooley a
midwife who lives in Albany Georgia this
is a story of how she helps people
people like Ida Fleming who engaged Miss
Mary to deliver her third child people
like Adam and Maribel Dudley newcomers
to Dougherty County who bring their
troubles to this Midwife in the County
Health Department are doctors and nurses
who help Miss Mary do the job to achieve
and thousands of other midwives all over
the south have dedicated their lives the
birthing of healthy babies always your
babies miss Mary
yeah there's oh my babies live it about
1,400 County one come this year here my
- I'm gonna send you a real little baby
picture this next with this baby why you
do their thing honey
nothing better than that
but I remember four years ago she was so
scared I had to take it to the clinic
myself back in those days our planet was
meeting at the old building dr. Andrews
have been out of Health Officer but I
guess just about a year
little mistakes and always try to help
Mama's feel these the first time in the
clinic of course our photo light already
what they're going to do
how did take each mother's temperature
and feel the pose every time a mother
comes to the clinic they measure her
blood pressure that's another way they
can tell is she keeping in good shape oh
yeah she ain't the thing she had better
do to get herself well so she can have
her baby more easy and normal either
doing just fine
the first visit they draw for little
blood for a test and then eight months
they do the same
that's to see if the mother need to take
the treatments every time the mother
comes to the clinic she brings along a
little bottle of her water for a urine
test that's to make sure that her kid is
working alright when our patient begins
a check-up early like I did then we miss
why they ain't so after running up
against something beyond our Hanlon
dr. Newton examine all the mother the
first time they come into the clinic and
again at eight months and between times
they've been eating when they come out
it's time for the doctor she know it
already was nothing for her to be scared
about
yes Ani but you know the planner now
come on oh let's look at you baby fangs
I always visit my mama's the head of
time if I possible can get to it cause I
know before I got here and Matt and I
would have everything fixed up nice
two days ago a baby delivered by a
midwife died when it ought to have lived
as your health officer it was my duty to
find out why that baby died my
examination showed that his court got
infected and you all know what that
means
something wasn't clean maybe the Midwife
didn't boil her scissors long enough or
it could have been that the dressings
she used wasn't sterile or it might have
been that she got in a hurry and didn't
wash her hands well
are you midwives in this county and fill
up a one of a reputation you work hard
and I know how difficult it is to keep
things clean in some of the homes where
you have to go but your record shows
that you can keep clean and when
something like this happens it's a
warning to all of us to us doctors the
nurses as well as to you midwives it
shows us how very easily we can slip
back when we get careless
I've been doing the same thing about
eighteen years but I still know I can
see if I don't keep checking on myself
these young girls would just start now
they have make them because they're
learning the right there to begin them
but you know folks can change too they
just put their mind to it
you people seem to be new around here to
me yes
well how far are you along with this
crazy attorney about six or seven months
I think what did the doctor say about
your pain son she ain't singing on that
oh well before I can take her case she
only have to see her that she'll have to
take a blood test and go through an
examination what's the law at fault it's
for the protection of huh and also her
bending how you know for what you don't
need treatments me damn is this your
first baby no-hitter
well there's Terry Manning how did you
get along with all your pregnant sister
our first when come dead the next one
drop before she got far along with it
well you just got to see your doctor
maybe I'll tell you what to do come on
down to the clinic Friday morning here
that's not gonna hurt you oh not it's
not very cute y'all stop by funny I'll
go with you thank you Miss Mara I'll
bring a bag all right dr. Newton send me
their lame been eating right and it sure
was up them he says every mother oughta
have a good examination all over it soon
as she thinks she's pregnant he said
maybe I love to start getting her
checkup months ago told miss penny sure
got a problem on her name
yes that was just my day for trouble
another lady they're just begging to be
my patient but I must know she needed
the doctor dr. Newton said I was right
about that thing and he showed me a
bengis sign lady has been having sharp
headaches all the time
the doctor said being pregnant by itself
there's no cause for a healthy woman to
feel old dizzy and drugged out ladies
ankle is all swelled up that's another
bad sign in the clinic that keeps
checking on three things the patient's
weight her blood pressure and her you
this latest clinic chart shows that she
has been putting on too much weight
especially in the last two months her
blood pressure had been drawing up
likewise way above what it ought to be
when the church with her urine had
showed up cloudy full of air veeneman
the doctor said instead of water Claire
like a well mothers after dachshund
you've got to explaining all of that
then the lady agreed herself it was
better to let the doctor Widow now the
nurse is always at guard with the
patients on what to eat and how to take
care of themselves
miss penny she keeps a sharp eye for the
penny patients like me BL and their
faith what she said they mostly gets
along okay
now I just didn't know how many they
would leave it out there livin my heart
down that harder bro
look like maybe I don't forgot what miss
Pina tuna te but you know as hard they
doin mean home and by yourself all day
long
that place in her rectum yes out there
I give up box myself to start to collect
enough of baby things but look like me
bill ain't thinkin bout nothin such as
then still it's hard to know just where
the person got on his mind sometime
but taking a look at all the mother that
come to the cleaning them that habit
role is very few
don't worry about that Tom look like oh
my babies comes at night
Cheryl been looking out for Miss Mary
took me out time wake up on it
you said it come into the stroller or
will be giving me the right quick
I need a little more water rent you off
my hand that matter that a DuPont
let me see now being me fresh news be
the bed really I wish to goodness all my
mother's could have everything fixed up
this night I don't have to move the bed
able to get on that night pay the
trophy's gonna move that table down this
way they they out my things oh you even
got the sculpture fixed on the paper
let's see how you doing are you fine
there ain't no word
I have watching the clock honey you can
walk around some if you want to
I remember either when I was having my
third baby
that little old hard-headed
just relax yourself and don't think
about nothing I have known patients to
drop right off to sleep
between times and just sleep and sleep
until the baby is almost here
there too when you feel one coming honey
but pretty soon I want you to start
pushing down and pant like a dog
remember now that to keep the babies
here some coming down to face what you
want this time I don't look they're all
our boy don't make no difference in me
warm up the blanket good night Mary
he'll be won't it none soon as I get the
drop things i holding we share now you
this too early to tell yet a while honey
man let's see if the germinal happy
you remember what I told you the last
time Adam Anderson your baby rattle
gotta make the wound drop you won't lose
so much blood
yeah smart fellow Booga he's catching on
to the idea wreck quick and maybe come
here to get all mold other stuff kind of
in my down
yes to go out the piece of clean day
tonight
this is early in the morning what
something wasn't cleaning something
wasn't cleaning something wasn't
cleaning no just can't keep the damn
thoughts preying on my mind
oh go away man I just not got in to be
hello media what you doing down on this
hey the baby come yet
oh man you guys can go bring me some
wood here some water
yeah I'm sure glad I brought some
newspaper some clean rags long that we
made there maybe then I just came to
live no baby on the flow now because
it's too dangerous
you'll find there's a heat better anyway
I'm go getting the things all balled up
me them then we'll be ready that Reza
can be with he'll come along so face
make a baby be it out there trucks get
something you sat in anyway Adam badly
come here quick I need you I want you to
go to the clinic and get in their
incubator quick this will come dad too
much man
dad what do you think hurry now
maybe bailout of MOS I'm calling saying
for you to do this to keep the baby warm
the old hanim and the more than you just
like this pit it may become too soon
Oh miss penny I'm glad you come let's
put it at the foot of the bed Adam works
out of the dress yes ma'am
you've got to keep this full of hot
water all the time to keep this baby
warm yes man that I better go cut some
more wood
now I'm going and fix me build something
to you that's a good idea
my what a husky little peanut we have
here there's nothing wrong with coffee
and grits but a mother should have milk
and vegetables and meat from the first
day on to be strong enough to take care
of her little baby I'll take care of mr.
penny and see this she gets done baby
Adam come on over input your name on
your baby's birth with it
once you're gonna call you madam jr. I
reckon
that baby's too low to live Amy Oh next
moment I go to see her and her baby
getting them look like everything's fine
without her and lo that baby I help
their little things you so yes yeah miss
Tina come to see bat out in her new baby
- and Matt it's kind of got
old-fashioned oddities
thanks mamas can't eat things like meat
dream miss platter said mamas can eat
anything after the baby's come they've
been hair done before the baby come and
they feel better for it - baby's cold
done okay
most of my patient is lying by now you
don't put on the everything but a
sterile dressing no breeze no pad
when I to come for her six-week checkup
maybe I was there too
poor girl I feel that sorry for I have
just kept bragging about that young man
all the time maybe I'll just kept
looking and thinking about her bouts and
you know he shakes our mothers make sure
that it didn't have no tears and that
the wound is all right
the doctor said Maybelle's come along
just fine and look like she's been
eating better to steal dr. Newton or
something else had been troubling me
bill this time but no that girl hey no
call to fit us they're causing full
month's time hi Adam jr. had rolled out
the beers prettier babies you ever so
we are more happy to maybe a wear a
unitard
I bet you probably baby miss Mary